let's jump back on the phones at 6 1 7 8
3 0 47 50 next I'm going to pick up on
our caller from the 6 7 8 area code
caller from 6 7 8 tell us who you are
what's on your mind today
hey David my name is Josh um from the
Griffin Georgia great and I have a
question do you think in the aftermath
of a Trump impeachment or read the
nation that it likely could trigger I
mean given the rise of this uh trumpian
kind of Coppola see ya
Oh horrible well it depends on how you
define civil unrest I mean I I do
believe that if Trump is either
impeached or resigns or is in any way
forced out of the White House
prematurely that there is going to be a
sort of uprising from some elements of
the trumpian right how violent they will
be I don't know and I'm hoping that that
there will sort of be the appropriate
resources in place from preventing to
prevent them from getting too violent
but I do believe that there is a faction
there and there a gun owning faction and
they are a violent faction that is going
to see it as you Trump being unfairly
forced out of office by fake news or
something like that so yeah that's
something I would be concerned about you
know what would be beyond smooth this
transition that you could see I mean
given the situation of the possible
violent right gun wielding right and all
right that does not believe that
mainstream news or anything that does
not align with their worldview you know
they just don't believe it so what would
you think will be the smoothest
transition there the smoothest
transition would be an uncontroversial
transition to Mike Pence right that
would be the smoothest where there would
be in the grand scheme of things
probably the least unrest that's what
I'm thinking Pat yeah and probably a
trump resignation too may be on some
sort of health reason a resignation
rather than impeachment yeah I don't
think that would rally up his supporters
too much yeah yeah I think that you know
if they keep going if there's more and
more signs of
the dementia stuff or they can kind of
couch it as health reasons whatever the
truth ultimately is that would probably
result in the smoothest transition all
right thank you sir
all right appreciate the call thanks
very much